[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
laurent joly bonjour bonjour merci
d'être merci d'être sur ce plateau vous
êtes historien spécialiste de l'histoire
de l'extrême droite et du régime de
vichy directeur de recherche au cnrs et
vous signez la rafle du vel d'hiv qui
est ici qui vient de sortir chez grasset
et qui vous a demandé je crois plusieurs
années de travail aidé enquête nous
sommes les 16 et 17 juillet 1942 l'un
des événements les plus tragiques
survenus en france pendant l'occupation
écrivez-vous l'arrestation en deux jours
par les autorités françaises
collaborationniste de 12 1884 hommes
femmes et enfants juifs en plein paris
arrestation qui sera suivi de leur
déportation dans les camps de la mort ce
que jacques chirac qualifiera dire et
parable en 1995 un épisode dont les
détails sont encore 80 ans plus tard
assez méconnu il vous fallait faire ce
travail et le détail du côté des
victimes étaient connues on sait il ya
eu énormément de témoignages on sait
comment les victimes ont ressenti ça on
s'est également bien sûr qu'est ce qui
avait précédé les accords policiers
entre vichy et l'occupant l'occupant en
faisant une exigence et vichy acceptant
d'y répondre et entrant dans un
engrenage criminel ce qu'on connaissait
moins et ce qui est finalement le coeur
de cette histoire c'est que c'est une
opération de police donc c'est avant
tout comme une opération de police que
je l'étudié avec sa préparation les
filles je commence à organiser
concrètement le la sélection des
victimes et puis le déroulé de ces vies
de ces de ces deux journées une journée
et demie du point de vue des policiers
et de leurs marges manoeuvres ce qu'on
se rend compte qu'il y avait des marges
de manoeuvre et que ça a eu un effet sur
les résultats qui ont varié d'un lieu à
l'autre d'un arrondissement à l'autre
d'une commune de banlieue à l'autre on
va y revenir dans un instant peut-être
pour ceux qui ne sont pas familiers de
cette histoire on va rappeler le
contexte de cette rafle ou plutôt de ces
rafles elles ont lieu donc le contexte
est celui d'un riche et un régime de
vichy collaborationniste au pouvoir
depuis 1940 convaincu en 42 que
l'allemagne en a yves a gagné la guerre
est enclin donc vous le disiez à
répondre aux demandes faites par part
par les nazis ville le régime de vichy
joue en fait à ce moment là sa dernière
carte peut pratiquement parce que pierre
laval est revenu au pouvoir pierre laval
c'était l'homme de la collaboration 1940
il était allé tellement loin que le
maréchal pétain l'avait renvoyé et donc
il est revenu en avril 42 avec une
feuille de route qui était très clair il
faut collaborer il faut donner le
maximum de gages aux allemands les
allemands à cette époque là ils veulent
des travailleurs en allemagne pour les
usines qui travaille pour l'effort de
guerre donc quand en plus ils vont
demander des juifs pour les embryons de
ses eaux pour pierre laval c'est évident
qu'il faut leur livrer le maximum de
juifs des étrangers des apatrides c'est
pour vichy des personnes indésirables il
faut s'en débarrasser ça fait deux ans
que vichy les met dans des camps en zone
libre par exemple donc l'engrenage de la
collaboration il était quasi inévitable
et il s'est hissé enclenchée alors la
demande est allemande mais le donneur
d'ordres lui bien français c'est rené
bousquet le chef de la de la police et
dans les jours qui précèdent la rafle
vous le disiez tout à l'heure va se
mettre en place et vous le décrivez avec
beaucoup de documents une minutie
bureaucratique autour notamment du
fichier juif lui alors le c'était pas du
tout évident en effet que le vichy la
france de vichy accepte de livrer des
juifs à paris parce qu'à paris on est en
zone occupée mais on se disait ça va pas
être forcément évident la population et
pas forcément très antisémite puis
s'agit là maintenant d'arrêter des
femmes et des enfants on avait déjà
arrêté en 41 des hommes mais c'était
pour les internes et sur place il s'agit
de les déporter donc on dit ça va pas
être si évident que ça et donc on confie
sa la police municipale or la police
municipale à les effectifs mais c'est
pas elle qui a le fichier le fichier
c'est un service service juif et donc on
va lui demander de sélectionner les gens
et donc ils vont prendre les juifs
apatrides de plus de 16 ans pour les
hommes et les femmes 55 ans limite d'âge
pour les femmes 60 ans pour les hommes
ils ont 27 me dévoiler un long voile et
fier qui sortent 27 mille 400 fiches
évidence des objectifs assez élevés y
pense que ces gens qui sont les plus
fragiles c'est pour la saison des juifs
polonais pauvres on se dit qu'on va
pouvoir on arrêtait 22000 à peu près
donc ils ont ils ont des objectifs
élevés et après il va y avoir la
pratique et de la la on voit qu'ils ont
moissonné le large possible ils ont pas
tenu compte des exemptions qu'ils auront
pu tenir qu'ils auraient pu le prendre
en compte on voit qu'il ya des infirmes
on voit qu'il ya des des gens qui ont
fait la guerre donc aurait dû être
protégé puis on voit surtout quand on
regarde les fiches qui dia les trois
quarts des enfants sont français les
gens des enfants français dont il
n'aurait pas dû être arrêté voilà donc
on a un objectif de chiffre qui est très
élevé et puis le résultat ça va être
qu'on va en trouver que 9000 sur des
vingt-sept mille 400 fiches donc voyez
un taux d'échec qui des deux tiers et on
a quatre mille enfants plus et c'est là
on va rentrer dans cet engrenage où pour
gonfler les chiffres pour faire en sorte
que le bilan qu'on présente idéalement
soit pas si ridicule que ça on va
insister pour que les enfants partent
tout de suite avec leurs parents on va y
revenir dans un instant il faut rappeler
qu'il n'ya aucun officier allemand qui
procèdent les 16 et 17 juillet aux
arrestations lui parce que bousquet qui
est chef de la police française qui est
un pur produit de technocratie française
lui considère que c'est l'honneur de son
administration qu'il n'y ait pas
d'opération mixte voyez pas de soldats
allemands et 2 policiers français comme
c'était le cas en quarante et un
ensemble sur le terrain dont il tenait
vraiment à ce que ce soit la police
française traditionnelle qui opère ici
12,7 sur cette singularité parce qu'on
voit pas ça ailleurs en europe des
policiers des agents de la paix enfin
des gardiens de la paix qui vont arrêter
des juifs au petit matin et doute la
question que vous posez parmi les
questions vous paie dans ce livre ses
essais voilà quatre mille cinq cents
policiers mobilisés comment ont-ils pu
alors comment ont-ils pu ce qu'on voit
c'est que en fait tout le coeur de mon
travail ça a été de rentrer vraiment
dans leur tête en fait leur mentalité
les marges de manoeuvre dont ils
pouvaient dont ils pouvaient faire faire
preuve et on voit qu'ils ont des marges
de man et on voit qu'en fait la plupart
ont fait leur travail mais sans elle et
qu'en fait il y en a un qui le dit dans
le livre
on pouvait on pouvait pas ne pas arrêter
de juifs pouvaient faire de notre mieux
on pouvait pas ne pas arrêter du fait en
fait on a l'impression qu'ils se sont un
peu entendu entre eux pour en arrêter
quelques-uns voilà une fois qu'on a
arrêté deux trois familles d'après en
fait plus de zèle on peut présenter à
ses chefs de trois familles donc il y en
a assez peu finalement qu'on fait du
zèle mais ça a suffi pour en arrêter en
arrêté 9 millions voit qu'il ya quand
même un taux d'échec des deux tiers donc
c'est ça le paradoxe c'est qu'il ya pas
une opération en europe de l'ouest qui
est équivalente arrêté treize mille
personnes jour ça c'est vu nulle part
ailleurs et en même temps c'est
considéré comme un semi échec par les
autori la plupart de ces juifs arrêtés
dont ils ont été emmenés au vélodrome
d'hiver un tiers des personnes qui ont
été arrêtés ont été emmenés directement
à drancy le vélodrome d'hiver n'existe
plus aujourd'hui c'est un stade couvert
dans le 15e arrondissement
l'histoire est connue ils ont passé
plusieurs jours dans des conditions
dantesques avant d'être déportés vers
des camps de transit seule une petite
centaine des personnes arrêtées ont
survécu et donc vous le vouliez à
l'instant et vous passer un long moment
dans livres à en parler contrairement à
certaines thèses a encore défendu
aujourd'hui par l'extrême droite
française c'est la théorie dite du
moindre mal vichy n'aura jamais autant
livré de juifs français aux nazis que
lors de la rafle du vel d'hiv parce que
pendant parmi les treize mille arrêté il
y a quatre mille enfants et la plupart
d'entre eux sont français lui si on vous
rentrez dans le doute dans ce jeu qui
est d'ailleurs assez ignoble de dire les
français auraient été puissent préserver
que les étrangers comme si livré des
enfants étrangers c'était moins grave
que livrer des enfants français donc cet
argument est ignoble mais en plus il est
faux parce que cette fameuse théorie du
moindre mal ou vichy aurait protégé les
juifs français pour et en sacrifiant les
juifs étrangers jamais vichy n'a livré
plus de vue français qu'en juillet 42 à
paris le 16 et 17 juillet trois mille
enfants français même à bordeaux en 44
même quand l'ami 10 ordonnera des
arrestations enfin le sécrétaire général
au maintien de l'ordre darnand ordonnera
des arrestations de juifs français on en
arrête ramoin vous voyez cette théorie
ne tient pas une façon de regarder les
chiffres on a en quelques semaines le
livret 25000 25 mille juifs et après la
machine va s'arrêter parce qu'il va y
avoir il va y avoir une émotion dans la
population gens vont être choqués et
vichy va être bien obligé de ralentir
donc vichy été en mesure de ralentir ce
qui fait pas mal des 42 où il veut
vraiment livré le maximum c'est la
politique de bousquet bousquet a dit
honnêtement je vous donnerai le nombre
de juifs étrangers que vous voulez c'est
bien ce qui se passe à l'été 42 mois des
enfants d'ailleurs et ses cépages assez
difficile à lire qu ils seront séparés
de leurs parents là encore
du jamais vu si j'ose dire et qui seront
déportés ensuite pour celle ci avec des
inconnus absolument là aussi on a en a
on a à faire et c'est vrai qu'en
travaillant sur ce livre j'ai vraiment
pris la mesure de ses singularités parce
que je me suis mais après tout est ce qu
on a fait pareil ailleurs ce qu il ya eu
des cas où déjà cette série de déporter
des gens mais en plus les séparait des
mères séparées de leurs enfants il y
avait quelque chose de d'extrêmement
cruel d'autant plus que les enfants
étaient libérables dire que déjà on les
a séparés cet été très très très dur
mais les enfants auraient pu tout à fait
ne pas être déportés vichy avait tous
les moyens de le faire dans bus qu'ils
étaient français ils ne le font pas ils
ne font pas parce qu'ils sont pris dans
l'engrenage criminels et que pierre
laval peut faire croire à l'opinion
publique qu'en fait les parents ils sont
en train de construire des baraques en
pologne puis les enfants ils viendront
une fois que les baraques seront prêtes
qui pouvait croire sa personne et les
gens qui venaient voir pierre laval
notamment le représentant de l'église
protestante qui est venu le voir qu'ils
étaient choqués mais vous comprenez pas
que les gens vont mourir et puis à laval
faisait semble pas comprendre il écrit
dans son journal le pasteur bonheur je
lui parlais massa qu'il me réponde et
jardinage
vouliez à l'instant contrairement à ce à
quoi s'attendait le gouvernement ces
arrestations que les officiers français
vous voulez organiser
relativement discrètement ont suscité
l'émoi à paris la consternation lui
évidemment la théorie on sort des fiches
on va aller au petit matin chercher des
gens mais en pratique c'est pas ça en
pratique il ya eu ça a été tout de suite
dramatique les gens pleuraient les
voisins sortait sur le palier
donc c'est aussi une raison pour
laquelle on n'a pas arrêté autant de
gens c'est que c'était c'était chaque
arrestation prenez du temps était lente
des femmes qui qui qui jeté des chaises
qui ce qui se débattait donc çà çà çà a
été publique la rafle du vel d'hiv est
éminemment public c'est d'ailleurs
terrible de voir fait qu'il n'ya qu'une
seule photo celle que l'on voit là n'a
pas de photos de cette de cette rave qui
a été pourtant quelque chose que tout le
monde a vu en tout cas dans les
quartiers de l'est parisien où il y
avait beaucoup de juillet dans le 11e
temps le quatrième dans le 20e
d'ailleurs il sort de cette photo est
intéressante c'est une photo de
propagande mais elle a été interdite de
diffusion lui c'est les allemands 41
avait fait de la propagande autour des
premières rafles il s'était dit on va
faire la même chose ils ont tout de
suite compris dès le 17 juillet dès le
lendemain ils ont compris que le plus la
population ne pourrait pas adhérer à une
propagande on voit qui est cette photo
que c'est une photo qui est conservé
dans les archives de la bibliothèque
historique de la ville de paris c'est
une photo qui vient du journal
paris-soir paris midi il y avait de
l'autre côté une légende antisémite on
voit qu'un tampon allemand via un refus
et les allemands ont donné l'ordre à la
presse parisienne qui étaient
complètement soumise qui étaient aux
ordres des allemands de ne pas dire un
mot de la raf qui s'était produite
l'avait donc voilà une opération que
tout le monde a vu mais le lendemain
dans le journal pas un mot il aura fallu
attendre
1995 laurent joly plus de 50 ans pour
que le rôle de l'état français de la
police soit reconnue de cette opération
qui s'appelait terriblement d'ailleurs
vent printanier c'était les mots de
jacques chirac lui reconnu que c'était
déjà il y avait déjà des travaux
d'historiens qui en parlait il y avait
déjà eu des des prises de parole comme
maire de paris jacques chirac avait déjà
fait quelques jours 1986 mais là qu'au
plus haut niveau de l'état y est un
homme politique
enfin le président de la république qui
reconnaît sa responsabilité de l'état
français dans est aussi une certaine
manière de la france parce que ce sont
des agents ordinaire de l'état vichy au
même moment à livrer aussi des réfugiés
zone libre donc il y avait besoin d'une
parole forte qui reconnaissent la
gravité de ce qui s'était passé petite
parenthèse vent printanier je le dis
mais c'est vraiment noyé dans le livre
c'est un mythe parce que tout le monde
parle de vent printanier et en fait
c'est ça s'appelait pas comme ça voilà
faut le savoir mais famille faisant qui
avait plein de d'idées reçues sur sur la
rafle sur la rafle du vel d'hiv autant
pour moi d'ailleurs on dit la rafle du
vel d'hiv et vous raconter qu'il y à il
y aura d'autres rafle dans l'été des
rafles après la rafle 1 au bout du
compte sur plusieurs mois un adulte sur
deux visés par le l'objectif initial a
été exterminée exactement vous avez tout
à fait raison de rappeler parce que on
va dire que les deux tiers ont échappé
au monde arabe donc que c'est un taux
d'échec important mais en vérité la
rafle a continué on a continué à traquer
ces gens qui étaient souvent polonais
qui parlaient mal le français et au bout
du compte on en a trouvé 4 milles en
plus des neuf mille adultes qui avaient
été arrêtés des 16 et 17 juillet et donc
il y aura des commémorations pour les 80
ans de la rafle du vel d'hiv bien sûr le
16 juillet prochain dont vous ferez
partie vous signez notamment un film je
crois pour france télévisions on vous
retrouvera dans le film que signes à
stéphanie trouillard pour france24 merci
beaucoup merci laurent joly être venu
nous présenter ce livre la rafle du vel
d'hiv donc il vient de sortir chez
grasset à l'occasion des 80 ans de cet
événement tragique merci encore si
beaucoup bonne journée à vous on se
retrouve juste après la pause avec
damien cottier m